I'm like why do you deserve a raise if
you've been running the city really like
what job in the world do you keep
getting more money all that when you're
like and there's cracks on the ground
there's crackheads on the ground there's
butt cracks in the ground like there's
everything so many cracks all
[Music]
over all right guys something bad
happened to a JK
fan no
we always do this oh because in this
case we can actually help oh how this is
one of our fans who lives in uh San
Diego San dieago someone from a Mexican
community so that's oh you you don't
like that no I do like I just feel bad
oh he feels bad I thought you didn't
like that she's from Mexican I'm from
San Diego oh then you're going to love
this okay she she messaged me and then
and then I was like messaged the just
kidding news cuz I don't want to talk to
I don't want to deal with this
yeah I'm busy I'm in Hawaii I'm on the
beach yeah don't tell me your struggles
this has one of your favorite elements
of Injustice okay you're going to you're
going to get real fired trust me is this
like Elmo trauma dumping I just learned
about that term you hear about Elmo on
real quick Elmo on Twitter he says how's
everyone doing today and then everyone
started like launching paragraphs oh I
did hear about that yeah pretty wild
it's and then I learned that's what
trauma dumping means it's not that so uh
what happened is uh
she her family they live next to a flood
channel in San Diego I believe oh
there's huge floods in San Diego
recently um it's it this neighborhood
has been begging the city for a long
time to unclog the channel and we all
know what that's like when the city
doesn't want to do something and you
just keep hounding them and you still
never do it they take a the thing will
happen that everyone's afraid of you
just need China to come and they'll
clean it up real quick have you seen San
Francisco yeah that's true so say
China's coming and oh [__] everything up
also shout out Flint Michigan nothing
ever happens oh nice yeah Onan fixed on
January 22 there was a a a pretty bad
rainstorm but it wasn't as bad as so
many others that they've gotten only a
very select few neighborhoods
experienced disaster because of this
flood Channel being clogged and what
happened is it caused a flood so
disastrous for her neighborhood that
every one of her family's cars is
totaled the um and they won't work cuz
they've been you know like submerged
pretty much salvage title all around for
everything um her entire family home was
completely flooded and now they're
staying at a motel kind of moving place
to place uh the city did declare a state
of emergency but they still haven't
provided any assistance they just like
de they're just like typical guys an
emergency is going on yeah I did a good
job M and uh tweeted about it one of the
most uh the way that they've even been
able to get by is just members of the
community helping each other out yeah uh
sharing resources getting their own
boats and ladders to get people up to
wow another example of the community
just coming together and government it's
like not helping and you're like wait I
spend so much money like every week
giving all this tax stuff to the
government I don't know where it's going
yeah here's a video that she sent us
about and this is uh so you can see
exactly what it looks like
wa damn that is crazy that is swimming
dude damn that's a whole freaking
River
[__] what is that a
refrigerator that's just because that's
at least 2 feet of water six for most of
them six good guess though good guess
well I was looking at the car I think in
yeah in some areas yeah too but I mean
she specified that they had I think in
their house it reached like 6 ft or
something people had to get up on the
roof and there were a lot of disabled
people that really couldn't uh do
anything about that so but neighbors
came helped put people on rooftops like
what a crazy thing to have to do right
but um the uh yeah so the bunch of
neighbors are grabbing kayaks and uh
literally just helping each other out I
don't think her family has an answered
yet on how they're going to get through
this she said her dad is older doesn't
speak English so um even trying to
navigate the assistance that's going to
be offered is kind of challenging for
them why did they just unclog the drain
man there's too many leaves and branches
like if your whole house and it's not
just your house right it's like the
whole Community like does the whole
Community like move out like what do
they do with those homes and it's like a
specific insurance that would only cover
this you have to get like flood
insurance specifically it's not like
normal and in San Diego why would you
have that and in any kind of flood or
any kind of disaster where it looks like
it might be the city's fault then what
you have is litigation between the
insurance company and the and the city
which never [__] ends it'll get
worked out
though in the meantime yeah you got
you're sleeping in a boat basically wow
and it's one of those things where the
the sad part like when I see this I It
just fits right in that little pocket of
like oh yeah it's a bad thing but not
bad enough to the people that need to
fix this that they might just sweep it
under and we might all forget about I
think if it's a poor neighborhood like
they don't fight as hard as rich
neighborhoods that can [__] some [__] up
with their own team of lawyers and all
that they're not ready to do that they
can't even like they're more preoccupied
with what are they going to eat and
where are they going to sleep that's the
crazy thing about it so uh here's like
another this is from one of the uh looks
like one of the city
meetings there's like a saying that says
we're Brown don't put us in the ground
we're all equal during a city council
meeting this guy who's disabled seen the
look on the guy's face just breaks my
heart yeah he's one of the people that
literally live has been asking them to
clean the drain I've been there eight
years
city has not done nothing to clear that
Creek we got we only got four storm
drains what was mayor Plan before plan
now we need something now we need home
homeless vouchers to hotels we need some
I'm disabled my daughter was out there
rescuing neighbors elderly neighbors no
help I was in the city calling the the
the city at 8:00 in the morning knowing
how it gets there no answers that's why
I'm frustrated cuz they know how the
community gets right there what last
week that little rain day you had the
pump truck was out there why weren't
they out there Monday knowing how that
neighborhood gets it's time for him to
step up and do the we're Brown don't put
us in the ground we're all equal he's
it's time for him to start a plan now
it's time for him to open his eyes so it
is that sentiment of like because the
neighborhood's predominantly Mexican
maybe San Diego doesn't give as big of a
[__] about it like kind of left behind
and stuff
yeah man that sucks dude so if you guys
would like to uh help assist our friend
there's going to be a GoFundMe Link in
the bio um it is going to be called San
Diego family help recover from flood
2024 this was a totally unnecessary
thing that never would have had to
happen had the proper channels been
clear for drainage that's the only
reason why it flooded which is really
sad I don't understand like why you see
the price for some of these things to
just get fixed right it's like 20,000 or
maybe even 100 maybe at the most a
million and then like all of a sudden
you see news like the city is now going
to be spending a billion dollars on a
new Statue or like and you're like what
the [__] and they couldn't solve this
[__] politicians give themselves a raise
every [__] year right but but no help
for for these guys that's the best thing
it's I'm like why do you deserve a raise
if you've been running the city really
shitty like what job in the world do you
keep
getting more money all that when you're
like and there's cracks on the ground
there's crackheads on the ground there's
butt cracks in the ground like there's
everything so many
all over and then the city just keep I
want to know like I don't know
enough this happens in there's so many
countless stories about local
governments [__] up like this right
so I want to know like why there is a
crack in the system where this keeps
happening well here I guess like here's
a small example that I had to deal with
my four years at Fashion District there
was a drain right in front of my studio
that was constantly being filled up by
homeless people using it for storage so
they would they would lift up the slab
and they would put bags of their stuff
in there and then what would happen is
if it rained and they didn't get their
stuff out in time it ended up clogging
further down the drain where you can't
access it so then it would rain and my
entire Studio would flood with water
because so the landlord was like that's
not my problem that's the city's problem
I would call the city I called every
possible number you could think of to
get that thing
unclogged the 4 years not one thing was
ever done other than me having to call
the fire department and the firefighter
was nice enough to try his best to
unclog it but he can't reach but he's
not a plumber he's a firefighter not a
pipe clogger he can't go 400 ft down the
underground to go get it but in that
four years I always got the same answer
like yeah we'll come next week we'll
come next month we'll come and not what
till this day someone else owns a studio
down they still have that problem that's
why we need Revolution but it's a thing
where like you can never expect like
yours local government will [__] you if
they can they will yeah it's a sad and
also like
it's not it's it it feels like it's the
most unmotivating job to have like have
you ever had to do some City [__] before
you go to the city and like half of the
folks look like they just hate life
they're pissed that you're there yeah
they hate that you're there like you try
to get a permit for something they're
like they look at you like why the [__]
are you even here I'm trying to flirt
with her right now yeah I was like I'm
just getting a marriage license I'm just
here to but it's also like why the [__]
are they there that's their job well
that's that's why you have so many of
these like investigative reporters that
are helping regular Joe's like actually
get answers from the cities they live in
it's because that is a sentiment like I
have a friend whose sister's a county
clerk here in La she handles lawsuits
that the city deals with when someone
slips on a pothole whatever they won't
even [__] address it until that
person is so annoying that they have to
yeah that's the that's the game it's
actually a good Tac instead of making
the actual problem go away the person
complaining is the problem and then they
make that go it's just the sil them ex
they don't fix the problem they pay them
off yeah it's just it's like you you'll
see the pothole your whole [__] life
until someone's pissed enough that it's
there or sues because of an incident or
if they finally get to it they spend
half a billion dollars to to install a
stop
sign yeah cuz they have to they have to
call in all of their homies and then
like yeah it's it's a I feel like it's a
constant effort that has to be performed
by the citizen in order to counteract
corruption corruption is default it's a
citizen's duty to like constantly
[__] flashlight that [__] it sucks
that it has to get to
this point for this entire Community but
we wish them well visit the GoFundMe in
the bio if you guys can and uh help
provide some support and hopefully we
can give more money to Ukraine too soon
too hope
go